entre les fai et utiliser tous les
moyens pour imposer leur vérité
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter ils étaient ni sur la liste
des morts ni sur la bbc insu réalité
hopitalisés il était nulle part est ce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane et en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à maintenant
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h prend pour décrypter les
grandit de l'actualité de la journée
n'oubliez pas de réagir sur le
télégramme d'ayrté france ne pouvait
prendre part au débat est interpellé
elle nous inviter au sommaire de ce
mardi 26 octobre la police prise pour
cible hier à lyon incidents dans le
quartier sensible de l'est du cher qui a
donné lieu à une passe d'armes entre
gérald darmanin et le maire écologiste
de lyon le premier reproche au second
l'absence de caméras de surveillance
malgré les rappels à l'ordre grégory
douce et fait tilt dans l'idéologie
concernant la sécurité des policiers et
des citoyens comme le dit notamment le
ministre de l'intérieur
le débat est ouvert en attendant vos
réactions sur télégramme
réunion d'urgence ce soir à huis clos du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu la crise
soudanaise est sur la table à la demande
de six pays dont la france une
préoccupation la communauté
internationale après le coup d'état
militaire et l'arrestation de ministre
les forces de sécurité sont déployés
avec leurs blindés sur les ponts et les
grands axes de khartoum malgré tout les
manifestations se succèdent dans la
capitale sur fond d'appels à la
désobéissance civile des syndicats fer
de lance de la révolte de 2010
à quoi pourrait ressembler le paysage
énergétique français dans 30 ans alors
que la coop 26 rouvre ses portes ce
week-end le gouvernement se penche sur
plusieurs scénarii possibles rapport du
réseau électrique français à l'appui
pour dit-on atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 alors peut-on se passer
du nucléaire on vous pose la question
dès 21h vous pouvez réagir dès
maintenant sur notre compte et les g rt
france
[Musique]
les questions sécurité au centre d'un
bras de fer politique près des tirs sur
des policiers hier à lyon des forces de
l'ordre cibles est en pleine opération
antidrogue dans le quartier de la
duchère pour gérald darmanin le ministre
de l'intérieur le maire écologiste est
négligé l'importance des caméras de
vidéosurveillance au nom d'une idéologie
on réponse grégory douce et considère
qu'il faut plus de policiers une
surenchère qui n'en finit par robin pu l
un important dispositif policier sur un
fond de passes d'armes entre
responsables politiques
ce mardi les forces de l'ordre ont
renforcé leur présence non le quartier
de la duchère à lyon un déploiement en
réponse aux tirs qui ont visé des
policiers de la bac ce lundi alors
qu'ils intervenaient sur un point de
deals du quartier les coups de feu n'ont
pas fait de victime mais ont suscité la
réaction du ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin réclame une réaction
rapide de la part des élus locaux j'ai
écrit ce matin au maire de lyon une
nouvelle fois ça fait trois fois que je
lui en parle en un an et demi de
remettre davantage de caméras dans les
endroits où il ya le plus de difficultés
de lutte contre la sécurité notamment
contre les points de dépôt les points de
deal nous appelons les maires de france
et singulièrement le ciel nord de lyon
de sortir d'idéologie et l'aider des
policiers et en mettant des caméras de
protection une sortie du premier
policier de france qui a du mal à passer
dont la préfecture du rhône l'année
dernière la ville comptait 558 caméras
de surveillance selon un recensement du
journal en ligne médiacité s'appuyant
sur les données municipal la réponse de
l'édile de lyon grégory douce et ne
s'est pas fait attendre
sur le quartier de la duchère il y a
déjà 60 caméras d'installer donc on ne
peut pas dire que le quartier n'est pas
vidéos protégées ce n'est pas vrai
l'idée c'est d'optimiser en permanence
notre couverture il n'y a pas
d'idéologie je suis très pragmatique on
cherche à faire en sorte que notre
dispositif de vidéoprotection soit le
mieux mailler possible ce n'est pas la
première fois que la municipalité
écologistes se retrouvent dans le viseur
du gouvernement le 7 octobre dernier une
première passe d'armes avait opposé le
ministre de l'intérieur au maire de lyon
sur le même sujet grégory douce et
réclame au gouvernement davantage de
policiers pour assurer la sécurité de sa
ville alors la question idéologique est
elle vraiment au coeur du problème dans
la municipale de plus d'ici pas lité
écologistes comme le sous-entend gérald
darmanin on attend vos réactions sur le
conte télégramme daté france place au
décryptage
[Musique]
est avec nous pour en parler alexis
poulain éditorialistes rt france bonsoir
alexis merci ce sera avec nous et d'ici
là vos côtés délégué unité sgp police fo
à marseille bonsoir et dc2 merci
également à vous d'être là une affaire
de sécurité qui devient éminemment
politique alexis ya à six mois de la
présidentielle oui évidemment surtout
que la ville de lyon était anciennement
aux mains de gérard collomb proche des
manuels macron qui avait aidé à fonder
le parti en marche elle a été volé ou
gagner plus tôt par élevées lors des
dernières municipales qui ont vu la
république en marche vers un score assez
petit et donc il ya comme une revanche
l'idée de dire que les écolos les maires
élevés notamment à lyon n'en ferai pas
assez sur la sécurité des citoyens c'est
un peu la rhétorique un gérald darmanin
le toujours plus sales toujours plus
dans la surveillance les drones qui
avait été retoqué pourtant par le
conseil d'état et qui reviennent la loi
sécurité globale qui était une loi de
surveillance totale on a l'impression
que gérald darmanin souhaite surveiller
toujours plus or il y a déjà des caméras
et elle fonctionne alors faut-il en
mettre d'avantagé ce que ça empêchera
les points de deal le problème de la
caméra c'est qu'elle arrive au dernier
maillon c'est à dire que entre le point
deal et l'arrivage de la marchandise il
ya quand même tout un
une chaîne qui l'a est plus difficile à
atteindre le trafic de drogue c'est
d'abord les cartels c'est aussi les
différents débarquement la police
travaille sur tous ces fronts là mais la
caméra c'est vraiment ce qu'il reste à
la fin quand on n'a vraiment pas réussi
à lutter contre ce fléau qu'est la
drogue et décide clairement gérald
darmanin qui critiquent la politique du
maire de lyon lui demande d'installer
davantage de deux caméras
gris bridoux ce qu'il affirme pourtant
que cette ville était plutôt calme
et qu'elle dispose de suffisamment de
caméras vous quelle est la réalité du
terrain vous avez eu certainement deux
de vos collègues lyonnais
alors vous serez qu'effectivement on a
ses problématiques année nationale n'est
pas propre à l'agglomération lyonnaise
ont les mêmes soucis sur marseille on
n'a ni ce qui est assez avant gardiste
sur le sujet je vous cache pas que
aujourd'hui on a certaines effectivement
idéologie politique certaine quelque
part franche des deux côtés politique
effectivement et de l'électorat en
question qui freinent des quatre fers
pour pas que ceci soit mis en place et
lorsque la vidéo aujourd'hui la vidéo
effectivement surveillance existe en
fait elle est utilisée soit uniquement
pour qu'elles ce qu'on appelle la
vidéo-verbalisation donc pour en fait ça
ça pas grand chose en terme de
vidéoprotection c'est simplement pour
vulgariser le l'idée et a ôté
spectateurs c'est simplement pour faire
baptiser des véhicules double file ou
stationnement gênant et nous ce qu'on
veut c'est la vidéoprotection et la
nuance elle est très importante et c'est
là que le dogmatisme grandes puissances
au niveau politique jacques on a des
personnes qui sont en l'occurrence qui
on refuse effectivement qu'on utilise
pour lutter contre sur la paix la
délinquance de voie publique la d'evp
parce que la vidéoprotection ça permet
de faire baisser 1,9 sentiment
d'insécurité de nos concitoyens sachant
qu'ils ne sont jamais seul est la
seconde chance est de faire baisser le
sentiment d'impunité car les vidéos de
la vidéoprotection nous permet
aujourd'hui pour les indicateurs
d'investigation de pouvoir travailler en
profondeur sur le modus operandi
certains criminels les directions de
fuite la possibilité de repérage avant
avant effectivement des faits qui
peuvent être commis donc une véritable
aujourd'hui il ya tout un travail en
amont et en aval qu'on arrive à faire
aujourd'hui avec avec l'appui de
protection et c'est vrai que l'on sait
qu'il ya un frein tout y est reparti
certaine partie de l'électorat qui
aujourd'hui le refuse à marseille on a
eu l'arrivée du président la république
qui nous a permis aujourd'hui de
remettre la promesse qui a été faite on
verra si elle est respectée mais plus de
400 de caméras de vidéoprotection parce
que de façon très pragmatique sans faire
de politique aucune c'était l'outil
aujourd'hui nécessaire une idée on
apparente pour prendre le cas de
marseille pour revenir elle suit les
jeux que je maîtrise d'autant plus ni
ceux ci c'est deux fois moins
d'habitants où marseille et on a deux
fois plus de cas via une caméra de vidéo
protection ce n'est pas normal
a dit que ses poulains vous avez cité
tout à l'heure un gérard collomb
évidemment ancien maire de la ville de
lyon ancien ministre de l'intérieur en
tout cas lui et il a une explication sur
sur ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans son
ancienne ville
il y a un problème avec la nouvelle
majorité qui se refuse à prendre des
mesures importantes contre l'insécurité
qui se multiplient dans la ville cette
majorité ne veut pas prendre en compte
les problèmes de sécurité il y a un
problème à partir du moment où les
délinquants savent qu'ils n'auront pas
une répression en phase 2 qui sera
sévère alexis poulain évidemment on est
dans ce que vous décriviez tout à
l'heure on est dans la politique mais
tout de même est ce qu'il n'ya pas un
peu en fond de vérité dans cette voie là
on sait très bien que les europe
ecologie les verts ne sont pas forcément
connus pour moi voilà leur fermeté en
tout cas ce n'est pas leur approche de
lutte contre l'insécurité
voilà du vrai du faux nom dans tout ça
je crois qu'il ya un peu de mauvaise foi
peut-être un constat aussi mais je ne
crois pas qu'une majorité quelle qu'elle
soit la tête d'une ville n'ait intérêt à
ce que l'insécurité grandit donc je ne
vois pas quel serait le calcul qu'elle
serait l'idéologie derrière celle du
maire élevé de lyon pour laisser faire
les délinquants je crois qu'il est assez
sévère avec les délinquants ils
parlaient de 60 vidéos caméras à la
duchère
alors il ya des moyens aussi est ce que
les budgets sont suffisants il ya aussi
pour rassurer et protéger les
populations c'est d'abord et avant tout
des policiers des policiers formés des
policiers sur le terrain on se rappelle
bien sûr de cette police de proximité
qui a disparu qu'on voudrait faire
revenir d'une façon ou d'une autre la
question également de la police
municipale armée ou non armé qui mérite
d'être posée anne hidalgo a tranché à
paris donc je pense pas que derrière
elle veille à une volonté que la
délinquance se multiplient dans une
ville comme une rencontre peut-être une
autre approche de la lutte contre
l'insécurité
évidemment que qu'il n'y a pas de
volonté que ça s'aggrave et dc de votre
avis sur cette question c'est tout
simplement une approche différente
en 7 lui en fait au neo on est vraiment
effectivement de la politique
politicienne et on est empreinte
dogmatisme quand j'entends effectivement
on parle de vidéoprotection parce qu'il
ya la vidéoprotection ya peut-être des
caméras mais pour voir comment ils sont
utilisés comme les s'est orientée est ce
que le parc est effectivement efficace
et efficient est-ce que les ponctions
notre police ont accès à ce système là
parce que je veux prendre un cas très
très très simple et très pratique sur
mars et par exemple on a un seul point
d'exploitation pour les policiers
nationaux pour cinq arrondissements dire
que c'est totalement saoul calibre est
donc aussi une volonté de certains et
certaines dogmatisme effectivement
qu'ils l'espèrent qui ne ne répare pas
les caméras qu'ils devraient l'être qui
ne fascine permet pas d'accéder aux
logiques lui permettait de pouvoir
travailler d'autant plus facilement da
c'est la même chose la seconde chose
opposer les renforts d'effectifs à la
vidéoprotection c'est quelque part
effectivement prendre en otage des
citoyens aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est
les deux lui faut des fonctions de
police pour exploiter les caméras ni il
faut des fonctions de police pour
arriver rapidement et faire cesser les
infractions et interpeller les individus
comme étant des agressions quelle
qu'elle soit mais nous avons aussi
besoin de ce monde technologique
effectivement qui est une arme à part
entière et un arsenal pour pouvoir
lutter contre les faits de délinquance
quel qu'il soit alexis poplin je vais
vous faire écouter une première réaction
celle d'eric un nom d'emprunt puisqu'il
n'a pas souhaité donner son nom c'est
justement un habitant de ce quartier
l'est du cher qui nous dit que les
choses se sont clairement dégradée au
fil des années
oui une ex à la une et une escalade et
jusqu'à présent on n'avait jamais vu
d'armes et là maintenant ça commence à
j'espère que c'est un on espère c'est un
cas isolé une période qui va être réglé
parce que jusqu'à présent la duchère
était inquiet un quartier assez calme on
connaissait pas ce genre de problème
avec des armes du moins cet habitant qui
se plaint de voir l'apparition d'armes
est ce que c'est un phénomène global est
ce que c'est un phénomène uniquement
dans ce quartier on
devient davantage violentes dans les
quartiers il y a davantage d'armes vrai
ou faux ou livré il ya un déni politique
là pour le coup moi ça me rappelle
l'épisode
des tchétchènes à dijon où le maire de
dijon devant les vidéos qui montraient
des armes dernière génération exhibé par
les clans locaux disait je n'ai pas vu
d'armes sur les vidéos donc il ya un
déni du politique ça il faut pas le nier
sur le fait que oui il y à des caches
d'armes dans ces quartiers là un arsenal
même récemment à marseille d'ailleurs un
arsenal énorme a été saisi avec des
lances mortier avec des gilets
pare-balles enfin vraiment tout un
arsenal de guerre quasiment donc il faut
pas se voiler la face je crois que là
aussi c'est du devoir de politique
d'arrêter d'être angélique ou de croire
que ça va s'arranger tout simplement et
le risque évidemment et tout le monde en
est conscient c'est l' escalade c'est si
jamais vous voulez aller chercher ces
armes ou faire comme l'ont fait ses
agents de la bac qui hier soir confronté
les dealers aux points de deal et bien
voilà maintenant les réponses qu'ils ont
c'est à dire des personnes qui
n'hésitent pas à tirer sur les forces de
l'ordre donc le danger il est réel pour
les agents de police il est réel pour
les habitants et la réponse elle doit
être évidemment exemplaire et il doit
être coordonnée parce que envoyer le
raid à contrecoup pour finalement de
fouiller deux barres de hlm et repartir
les mains vides ça ne fonctionne pas
donc il faut la un plan peut-être
nationale qui doit être coordonnée par
le ministre en l'occurrence avec la
police nationale avec les unités
spéciales pour saisir ces armes parce
que ça devient vraiment catastrophique
et on va voir ce genre de
malheureusement de passes d'armes se
multiplier sur le territoire marseille
bien sûr à les règlements de comptes
entre trafiquants mais maintenant les
forces de l'ordre vont également être
prises pour cible c'est déjà le cas
également sur le terrain mais pas
forcément par des armes et des tirs de
mortiers de feux d'artifice les pompiers
également donc cette violence on l'a
laissé s'installer de peur justement de
l' escalade aujourd'hui l'escaladent l
est on tire à balles réelles sur des
policiers en intervention donc il va
falloir réagir et ça le ministre ne peut
pas non plus faire un discours et tout
mettre sur le dos des élus locaux c'est
aussi là au ministère et la police
nationale de prendre les dispositions
qui sont nécessaires et décide de choses
dans ce que vient de me dire alexis
poulain le déni par rapport à tous
politiques concernant cette question des
armes et aussi on laisse peut-être faire
la violence de peur que ça explose
vraiment votre avis en fait tout savoir
qu'on a mis en place une stratégie du
harcèlement c'est tragique du
harcèlement sous-entend qu'on essaye de
d'appréhender et de chimie au maximum du
trafic de stupéfiants voilà donc on est
présent plus souvent possible on fait
des passages ont interpellé les auteurs
les vendeurs on interpelle les
consommateurs on ne verbalise envers ben
ali ceux qui traînent dans les cages
d'escalier il ya tout un arsenal
juridique aujourd'hui et administratifs
qui est mise en place donc oui
effectivement c'est les personnes qui
sont ces malheureux dire ça mais au mini
bulle et par l'argent c'est totalement
vie n'a à aucun moment les règlements de
compte c'est pour une histoire dé vous
c'est vraiment des gens qui n'ont aucun
intérêt que l'appât du gain c'est du néo
libéralisme exacerbé en fait si je puis
dire en fait on en passe de personnes
qui ne veulent que gagner d'argent un
point de lille à marseille c'est entre
30 et 80 mille euros par jour et c'est
pas effectivement 3 mars et c'est pareil
dans toutes les villes de france donc de
chiffre d'affaires donc donc est
aujourd'hui dont copie nous irons les
voir plus mais harcèleront plus nous
gênerons le trafic c'est ça le business
il n'y a pas d'autre mot puisse
effectivement cnra mois voire doit être
pas avoir les nerfs exacerbée pascal
falloir rembourser parce que quand les
interpelle effectivement des auteurs
qu'on interpelle du poids du policier
qu'on appréhende de l'argent et cela
falloir que les trafiquants d'hommes les
rembourser à leur grossiste
effectivement anti cumul des dettes donc
à ce moment là effectivement ils sont
sur les dents quand nous venons gêner le
travail tue pétillante par la présence
de interpellons le char bonheur le
dealer le guetteur et et nous sommes là
tous les jours dans mon cas ce sont
effectivement leur économie soit disant
père m selon le et qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement qui les gêne donc c'est
pour ça qu'on n'a pas d'individus qui
sont de plus en plus déterminé parce
qu'on gâche le plus en plus
effectivement la perspective d'un
bandage fiducie quel qu'il soit donc oui
effectivement on est en face à des
individus qui monte crescendo parce que
le harcèlement que nous leur mettons ont
passé aujourd'hui est de plus en plus
important donc malheureusement il faut
absolument trouver des solutions pour de
l'écarter de façon pérenne et pour
pouvoir effectivement au niveau pénal
que c'est une avenue soit appréhendé une
loin de ces quartiers al plus tantôt si
on va terminer ce n'est pas avec un
message télégramme d'une téléspectatrice
fabienne possible que votre douce et
préfèrent la liberté à la surveillance
systématique du citoyen s'il n'a pas
décidé de truffes et sa ville de caméras
comme le souhaite le ministre est bien
la liberté a toujours un prix peut-être
aussi celui d'un moindre contrôle de la
délinquance nous dit fabienne justement
lexsi poulain c'est est ce que j'ai
essayé de vous dire tout alors peut-être
une autre approche tout simplement et il
faut parfois peut-être en payer le prix
oui alors évidemment mais enfin payer le
prix si c'est au prix de vies humaines
je crois que c'est pas c'est pas un bon
calcul est donc il ya un vrai sujet de
société sur la sécurité mais aussi sur
le trafic et à grande échelle s'attaquer
au cartel c'est une coordination
internationale que ce soit interpol et
autres et la vidéoprotection attention
c'est un terme de novlangue la vidéo n'a
jamais protégé en réalité elle permet de
surveiller elle permet peut-être
d'identifier des hauteurs de larcins
mais c'est a posteriori c'est très
difficile d'agir si on voit quelque
chose se passait de toute façon donc
hier à l'heure quelques pas c'est comme
si on fait croire aux gens que la
vidéoprotection va les protéger non elle
elle les surveille elle permet de
surveiller de voir qui sont les auteurs
mais encore une fois il faut une réponse
coordonnée il faut des policiers sur le
terrain et il faut s'attaquer au trafic
de grande ampleur au cartel parce que
évidemment quand on est sur un point de
lille c'est le maillon faible c'est la
fin du trafic mais et c'est extrêmement
difficile de démanteler évidemment ces
réseaux de trafic il y en a eu 1
récemment aux pays bas et les porcs sont
bien entendu des lieux de passage donc
il ya tout un travail de fond qu'on ne
voit pas évidemment puisque c'est
l'intelligence et la sécurité intérieure
qui sont aussi responsables de cette
protection là parce que le deal peut
continuer longtemps parce que c'est un
business qui rapporte comme vient de le
dire monsieur et ça va continuer parce
que il n'y a pas d'autres débouchés
parce qu a pas de débat non plus sur
comment encadrer aussi si on devait
légaliser ou non certaines drogues comme
le cannabis ou
ou
d'autres drogues moins dure que celle
qui existe ce débat là il a un peu lieu
à l'assemblée nationale mais encore une
fois si vous allez dire c'est un choix
de société c'est un débat politique et
il ya beaucoup de politique dans la
question de sécurité et de liberté et on
peut le comprendre mais je crois que
citoyen comme élus locaux n'ont pas
intérêt à ce que la délinquance se
multiplient et profite du traffic
évidemment merci beaucoup alexis poulin
et d'ici d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
décryptage ce soir
l'antisémitisme au coeur du procès des
meurtriers présumés de mihai knoll qui
s'est ouvert aujourd'hui à paris cet
octogénaire rescapé de la rafle du vel
d'hiv avait été assassinée il ya trois
ans à son domicile il ya une semaine une
plaque a été installée en sa mémoire
hélène masquelier
11e arrondissement au beau milieu du
boulevard de ménilmontant une allée et
baptisé en souvenir de ce drame qui
avait créé un émoi national
le 23 mars 2018 mireille knoll 85 ans
était retrouvée morte tuée de 11 coups
de couteau dans son appartement
c'était une promesse faite par la maire
de paris en 2018 anne hidalgo a rendu
hommage à l'octogénaire un repère office
vieux pour toutes celles de feu
parisienne paris vers visiteurs
touristes qui voudraient aussi rendre un
hommage à mirer knoll et faire vivre sa
mémoire sur la plaque cette inscription
mireille knoll lâchement torturées et
assassinées parce que nés juive le
caractère antisémite de ce meurtre avait
été retenu par les deux juges
d'instruction en juillet 2020 cette
cérémonie était également l'occasion de
délivrer un message le combat contre
l'antisémitisme doit nous rassembler
c'est un combat profondément
démocratique et républicain et au delà
des clivages politiques qui était
important que chacun marque bien cette
volonté de lutter contre toute forme
d'antisémitisme
aujourd'hui et demain car
l'antisémitisme est un poison
l'antisémitisme est un venin
qui divise profondément et qui est en
danger pour l'avenir de nos sociétés
démocratiques
les meurtriers présumés comparaissait ce
mardi devant la cour d'assises de paris
un procès très attendu par la famille de
mireille knoll nous on attend une
justice implacable j'espère qu'ils vont
être condamnés
et qu'ils n'auront même pas le droit de
sortir avant la fin
avant la fin de leur punition
il ne mérite pas de profiter de la vie
ces gens là un meurtre contestée par les
deux suspects qui ont été entendus ce
mardi pour le début d'un procès qui doit
durer jusqu'au 19 novembre et notre
reporter katia technique suit ce procès
pour rt france qu'autour avec elle sur
cette première journée devant la cour
d'assises de paris
au cours du procès de l'assassinât de
mireille knoll il faudra établir les
responsabilités de ce meurtre car les
versions des deux accusés s'opposent
toujours quatre ans après les faits il
s'agit de yassine mihoub le voisin de
mireille knoll et d'alexandre car un
bacchus et chacun rejette la faute sur
l'autre cet après midi n'a entendu les
accusés yacine youtube et sa mère dans
le cadre des enquêtes de personnalité
alors la mer tout d'abord qui avait lavé
le couteau après le meurtre et la
troisième mise en examen elle évoque un
fils alcoolique aux comportements
violents qui on voulait à la terre
entière et qui lui pourrissent élèves et
puis yacine nuke vers lequel tous les
regards se tournent qui était bien sûr
le voisin demi räikkönen est accusé de
l'avoir poignardée il s'est exprimé
d'une voix claire posé il reconnaît la
dégradation c'est à dire l'incendié de
l'appartement mais pas les faits de vol
ni de meurtre aggravé il a évoqué les
violences de son père durant son enfance
et un viol subi à l'âge de 12 ans à
l'internât pour lequel une plainte a été
déposée quelques années plus tard un
traumatisme qui l'aurait rendu amer et
violent envers lui-même et les autres
délinquants multirécidivistes menaçant
il avait aussi l'habitude de voler toute
sa famille pour acheter de l'alcool et
de la drogue des addictions qui selon
lui ne le rendait pas plus violent mais
les nombreux faits de délinquance
parlent d'eux mêmes voir les accusés a
évidemment beaucoup peiné la famille de
l'octogénaire assassiné on écoute son
fils daniel knoll ainsi que l'avocat de
la famille knoll gilles william
goldnadel est ce qu'on nous a décrit est
tellement horrible un pauvre mère
c'est insupportable de les voir ici
c'est très difficile je me dis comment
des êtres humains
peuvent faire des choses pareilles je
n'attends pas grand chose d'eux se sont
ils sont bien trouvés tous les deux ce
sont deux menteurs patentés
c'est pas moi qui vous le dis quand vous
écoutez ce que disent leurs parents la
mère par exemple de yacine guillaume
ne cesse de dire que son que son fils
est un menteur donc comment voulez vous
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que j'attende
de quelqu un dans chaque mot qui sort de
sa bouche est un menteur et d'autre part
un éclairage particulier quand même de
ce genre de personne parce que bien sûr
ce sont des êtres humains mais on a
quand même affaire pardon de vous le
dire comme ça à la lie à la lie de
l'espèce humaine il reste bien sûr à
explorer le caractère antisémite du
meurtrier ainsi mihoub avait fait des
recherches sur l'islam salafiste ou les
frères musulmans peu de temps avant le
drame le voisin de miracle a là aussi
été repérés en prison pour avoir tagué
des inscriptions favorable aux attentats
de charlie hebdo et de l'hyper cacher
dans sa cellule des éléments à charge
répertorie dans l'instruction
les espoirs des soudaines et de voir
leur pays épousé la voie démocratique
s'éloigne un peu plus chaque jour le
processus de transition a été balayé en
quelques heures à peine ce lundi par un
coup d'état militaire
depuis le soudan en plongée dans
l'inconnu arrestation 2010 dont le chef
du gouvernement appelle à la
désobéissance civile la situation est
hors de contrôle à khartoum les
manifestations de masse sont sévèrement
réprimées par l'armée bilan selon des
médecins sur place au moins sept morts
et 140 blessés amaya soubelet
[Applaudissements]
scène de révolte et contestation
populaire c'est le scénario dans lequel
est plongé le soudan ce pays l'un des
plus pauvres du continent voulait se
diriger vers un régime démocratique sous
l'égide des militaires et des autorités
civiles de transition qui se
partageaient le pouvoir
mais ce lundi les forces armées ont
arrêté le premier ministre ainsi que de
nombreux membres du conseil de
souveraineté qui refusait un coup d'état
l'arrivée au delà car le premier
ministre anne decq était chez lui mais
nous avions peur qu'il lui arrive
quelque chose il est maintenant chez moi
nous étions assis ensemble hier soir il
poursuit sa vie normalement et rentrer
chez lui lorsque la crise sera terminée
et que toutes les menaces auront disparu
mais pour l'instant il reste chez moi
dans les rues de khartoum
les voix s'élèvent contre le coup de
force militaire nous rejetons
entièrement la déclaration du général
abdelfattah al bourhane nous
revendiquons un gouvernement civil et
demandons la dissolution du conseil
militaire nous ne négocierons plus avec
l'armée notre peuple est persévérant et
patiente continuera à exiger un
gouvernement civil
des rassemblements qui ont fait
plusieurs décès du côté des manifestants
le réseau internet du pays tout entier a
été coupée alors que la télévision
d'état a été prise par les militaires
après avoir dissout les autorités de
transition le général abdel fattah al
bourhane a promis la formation d'un
nouveau gouvernement
il confirme également des élections
libres pour 2023 après 30 ans de pouvoir
d'omar el béchir si en 2010 neuf
militaires et civils se sont accordés à
le chasser aucune entente n'a su être
trouvée depuis mission politique la
communauté internationale a fermement
condamné le coup d'état soudanais
les etats unis ont gelé 700 millions de
dollars des deux pays après le
renversement du gouvernement et demande
le rétablissement de la transition
du côté de l'onu
le son de cloche est similaire
je demande à chacun de faire preuve de
la plus grande retenue et j'appelle
l'armée a relâché tous ceux qui ont été
arrêtées illégalement aujourd'hui et je
demande à toutes les parties de
retourner au dialogue et de restaurer
l'ordre constitutionnel
et de ne pas mettre en danger la paix et
la transition politique
ce mardi le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
doit tenir une réunion d'urgence à huis
clos sur la situation au soudan qui voit
de plus en plus son avenir démocratique
s'assombrir
la réunion en urgence donc du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu ce soir à 22 heures à
l'appel de six pays dont la france et
pour la russie ce coup de force ce site
est le résultat logique d'une politique
ratée accompagné d'une ingérence
étrangère d'ampleur la correspondance à
moscou de maylis d'estrées le crème bien
se dit inquiet par la situation actuelle
et souhaite stabilisation le plus
rapidement possible dmitri peskov
porte-parole du président russe a appelé
toutes les parties à agir avec retard
recruter
nous sommes bien sûr préoccupe et nous
aimerions évidemment que la situation
revienne sur la voie constitutionnelle
dès que possible
nous appelons bien entendu toutes les
parties à faire preuve de retenue en
effet le soudan est très important pour
nous en ce qui concerne le développement
de nos relations dans divers domaines et
nous observons très attentivement ce qui
s'y passe
concernant un éventuel soutien de moscou
à l'égard d'une des parties le
porte-parole de la présidence russe a
souligné que les soudanais devaient
eux-mêmes régler la situation un avis
également mis en exergue par la porte
parole du ministère russe des affaires
étrangères
aux côtés une ingérence étrangère
massive dans les affaires intérieures de
la république à tous les niveaux a
conduit en pratique à une perte de
confiance dans les autorités de
transition chez les citoyens soudanais
ce qui a provoqué de nombreuses
manifestations et une instabilité
généralisée dans le pays y compris la
séparation de fait de plusieurs de ces
régions nous sommes convaincus que les
soudanais peuvent et doivent résoudre
par eux mêmes les problèmes internes et
déterminé le vecteur de développement
souverain de leur pays en fonction de
leurs intérêts nationaux
la fédération de russie continuera de
respecter le choix du peuple ami
soudanais et de lui apporter toute
l'assistance nécessaire
un peuple dont le désespoir et la
détresse ont été d'après la porte parole
de la diplomatie russe ignoré par les
autorités de transition et leurs
conseillers internationaux pour maria
zakharova les récents événements
témoignent de la crise grave qui touche
tous les domaines de la vie politique et
économique dans le pays et son jeu si tu
le résultat logique de la politique
défaillante menée ces deux dernières
années au soudan et on va plus loin avec
notre grand reporter rt france régis le
sommier bonsoir régis après à 30 années
de règne d'omar el béchir la transition
politique au soudan est clairement en
péril les militaires sont en train de
réussir ce qu'ils ambitionnaient de
faire depuis longtemps évidemment oui il
ya comment il ya une dizaine une comment
noyau dur de militaires qui souhaitait
reprendre le pouvoir et qui n'a pas du
tout accepté de cette transition
démocrate damon démocratique donc qu'ils
acceptaient finalement de risque et le
le mano à mano avec le peuple puisque ce
qu'on voit finalement c'est que les
soudanais s'était mis dans l'idée après
ce règne dit de extrêmement long omar al
béchir qui avait règne quand même qui
était d'un des pierrots estime des pires
dictatures d'afrique à l'époque faut
savoir que c'était aussi ses 30 ans
ça a été le théâtre par exemple de
l'accueil de d'oussama ben laden
quelqu'un qui est qu'à un moment trouvé
refuge au soudan donc on était dans une
dans une dictature du riz dans une
dictature islamiste également donc voilà
la transition est bien
elle l'était naissantes elle commençait
à se faire et il y avait évidemment des
militaires derrière qui ambitionnait
justement d'y mettre un terme et c'est
un peu ce qui s'est passé avec quand
même beaucoup de questions encore en
suspens où se trouve le président amdocs
aujourd'hui donc la junte 10 qui a pris
le pouvoir dit qu'ils ne sont pas en
danger la prendre les principaux
ministres également ont été kidnappés
véritablement et donc qu'il ya un vrai
un vrai problème avec quand même des
moyens de levier et de la communauté
internationale en aime donc réunir au
coc au conseil de sécurité de l'onu mais
surtout faire elle peut justement les
américains déjà ont décidé de suspendre
l'aide de 2 700 millions de dollars
qu'ils octroient au soudan tous les ans
une partie de cette aide d'environ 365
millions ont déjà été versés donc mais
la suite risque de ne pas l'être non
plus l'europe c'est à hauteur de 52
millions
ça c'est des sommes qui n'ont pas encore
été versées qui pour le moment n'ont
être bloqué en attendant justement
peut-être une issue favorable ou en tout
cas mais si la junte au pouvoir se
maintient il est évident que voilà c'est
une manière de couper les vivres à temps
qu'est ce que peut faire le soudan
qu'est ce que peuvent faire les
militaires ils ont l'egypte au nord
l'ethiopie mais on sait que l'ethiopie
et le soudan sont très liés mais
l'ethiopie et engagés dans cette guerre
notamment dans cette région
sécessionniste du tigré ya l'arabie
saoudite aussi à l'est qui s'y tient
voilà qui est un soutien donc mais
est-ce que ce sera suffisant pour régler
un certain nombre de problèmes comment
dans le pays rien n'est rien n'est sûr
on a vu la position différente de la
russie sous la russie a des intérêts au
soudan différentes seul rhino
international y avait ma main un projet
d'installation d'une base militaire
russe au soudan tout ça est un geste qui
dit hein
je cite le coup de force et de résultat
d'une politique ratée et d'une ingérence
étrangère
d'ampleur il ya du vrai dans cette
analyse ou c'est de bonne guerre mais je
pense que c'est une question d'intérêt
chacun d'église derrière une façade de
d'expression de ta termes de commandes
de cesser le langage diplomatique qui
parle en réalité il ya les intérêts des
uns et des autres qui sont clairement
exprimés la transition démocratique
quand on n a passé trente ans sous une
dictature effectivement ça peut être que
empirique et voilà ça évidemment ça ne
satisfait pas tout le monde mais on voit
qu'il reste toujours au soudan des
habitudes justement héritées de l'ère
l'air bachir et qui ont tendance à
persister et qui se manifeste encore une
fois sous la forme d'un coup d'état
militaire quid de la population dans
tout ça parce que le soudan le rappelle
est l'un des pays les plus pauvres du
monde les soudanais sont dans la rue
d'ailleurs on dit ce soir que deux que
des tirs soient entendus actuellement
dans les rues de khartoum
la population prise en étau prise en
étau avec une population qui avaient cru
elle je pense dans une grande partie de
2,2
ajustement voir autre chose à comment
est-ce que le pays depuis donc le le le
départ de le 11 avril 2010 9,2 d'omar al
bashir avec espérait justement qu'ils
puissent se cumulent parce que c'est la
rue aussi il y avait déposé le dictateur
est donc là il y avait que je pense des
espoirs et désespoirs qui
malheureusement sont en train d'être
réprimée puisque les manifestations
étaient interdites des tirs des tirs oui
que va-t-il se passer est ce que la
population qui s'est révolté vais avoir
les moyens de continuer à faire cette
pression au contraire ça va être la
répression tous azimuts
c'est ce qui va se passer dans les
prochains jours et évidemment c'est très
critique et tout le monde va regarder ça
et va suivre cette histoire de façon
attentive merci beaucoup régis le
sommier d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur sur rt france et un coup d'état
militaire au soudan qui remet en
perspective une démocratie malmenée dans
de nombreux pays d'afrique le continent
qui fait face à au 11e putsch en dix ans
retour en images sur une décennie de
coups de force avec théo coin
l'afrique un continent de 54 états sur
lequel on ne compte plus les coups
d'état lors de la dernière décennie neuf
pays africains ont connu des
renversements de gouvernement par les
armes un chiffre édifiant qui s'illustre
particulièrement au mali un pays qui a
été le théâtre de trois coups d'état en
moins de dix ans le premier intervient
en mars 2012 le président amadou toumani
touré est renversé après une décennie au
pouvoir après une période de transition
c'est ibrahim boubacar keïta qui lui
succède grâce à son succès à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 13 réélu en 2018
son mandat prend fin le 18 août 2020 de
façon assez similaire à celle de son
prédécesseur
nos murs ma décision
de quitter mes fonctions
par ma fonction à partir de ce moment
et comme toutes les conséquences de
droit
la dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
et celle de gouvernement un coup d'état
qui on sera suivi d'un autre neuf mois
plus tard personnage central de cette
deux derniers putschs le colonel a si
meego ita nouveau président de
transition et véritable homme fort du
pays autre coup marquant celui mené par
l'armée égyptienne en 2013 contre le
tout nouveau président mohamed morsi élu
démocratiquement après la chute d'hosni
moubarak renversé par les contestations
liées au printemps arabe le président
islamiste ne reste qu'un an au pouvoir
c'est un autre vaste mouvement populaire
qui conduira l'armée a destitué mohammed
morsi en 2014 après une courte
transition abdel fattah al-sisi un
militaire de carrière est élu avec 87,1
pour cent des voix est depuis resté à la
tête du pays
autre exemple celui de la chute d'alpha
condé en guinée après avoir été réélu en
octobre 2020 pour un troisième mandat
malgré de forts soupçons de fraude le
président de la guinée et finalement
renverser ou en donnant plus tard et 8
loupé une forme d'art un move nous
comité national pour le rassemblement et
le développement avons pris nos
responsabilités
quand tout cela a répété
nous voulons placer la transition qui
s'ouvre sous l'eau si des les repérages
et d'illuminer ouvert et profiter avec m
avec tous les fils du pays si l'armée a
promis une concertation nationale afin
de transmettre le pouvoir aux civils la
constitution d'un gouvernement
démocratique semble être un lointain
mirage une situation que ne connaît que
trop bien le tchad pays qui a récemment
vécu des événements similaires une
véritable faillite de la démocratie en
afrique qui fragilise la stabilité du
continent africain première victime de
cette frénésie de coup d'état les
habitants des pays concernés
21% de la population africaine est
considéré comme sous alimentés ce qui
représente plus du double que n'importe
quelle autre région du monde et autres
coups d'état celui du 1er février
dernier en birmanie une situation qui
s'invite au sommet de la zean qui s'est
ouvert aujourd'hui dix pays d'asie du
sud est y participent mais pas la
birmanie précisément la junte a décidé
de boycotter ce rendez vous leur chef
verront pas été conviés des discussions
que doivent rejoindre les dirigeants
russes chinois ou encore américains
parmi les sujets sur la table la
croissance économique ou encore la
sécurité et pendant ce temps alex
dirigeante birmane aung san suu kyi est
toujours assiégée a signé pardon à
résidence huit mois après le putsch jugé
après avoir été renversé par les
militaires l'ancien prix nobel de la
paix a été entendu pour la première fois
aujourd'hui par un tribunal de la
capitale birmane est une instance qui
pourrait la conduire derrière les
barreaux pour de nombreuses années
martial pure avec nicolas fontaine
propulsé à la tête de son pays en 2016
son règne ce sera brutalement stoppé
cinq ans plus tard
hanks englouti 76 ans aujourd'hui avait
reçu le prix nobel de la paix en 1991
pour avoir été la figure de proue de
l'opposition en birmanie
le 1er février dernier la dirigeante est
renversé par un coup d'état militaire
est assigné à résidence elle s'est
exprimée pour la dernière fois par la
voix de son avocate au mois de mai
dernier
et le peuple reste en bonne santé
affirme que la ligue nationale pour la
démocratie et existera tant que le
peuple existera car elle a été fondée
pour les gens
son arrestation est d'abord justifié par
des délits mineurs importations
illégales de talkie walkie et non
respect des restrictions liées aux
coronavirus
la junte l'accusent ensuite d'avoir reçu
cinq cent mille euros de pots-de-vin et
plus de 11 kilos d'or de la part d'un
allié politique
autre accusation la plus lourde retenues
contre eux en cinq sets chi la violation
d'une loi sur les secrets d'état datant
de l'époque coloniale chaque motif est
passible d'une peine allant jusqu'à 15
ans de prison son procès s'est ouvert le
14 juin dernier et se déroule à huis
clos ses avocats dénoncent des
accusations absurdes ayant pour but de
la tenir à l'écart de la scène politique
du pays et de salir son image
depuis le 1er février plus de 1100
birmans ont été tués et huit mille sont
emprisonnés dont des élus des militants
des journalistes et des membres du
personnel médical venus en aide aux
manifestants anti junte plus de 200000
birmans ont déjà fui leurs terres
la direction présents les états unis où
l'attaqué meurtrière du capitole à
washington refait parler d'elle dix mois
après l'assaut une longue enquête du
magazine rolling stone met en lumière
des complicités entre assaillants et
élus du congrès ou encore collaborateur
de la maison blanche on en parle tout de
suite avec notre correspondant thomas
bonnin washington bonsoir format
qu'est ce qu'on apprend donc dans cet
article qui interpelle d'ailleurs la
commission spéciale de la chambre des
représentants
et bien ce qui est exposé dans cet
article c'est donc cette proximité entre
des représentants politiques et des
organisateurs des manifestations qui se
sont déroulées autour du capitole 6
janvier l'article s'appuie en réalité
sur les témoignages de deux sources
anonymes qui sont présentés comme des
organisateurs de manifestations en
soutien à donald trump est l'une des
affirmations les plus frappantes de
cette enquête publiée dans le magazine
rolling stone c'est lorsque ses sources
explique avoir eu des échanges avec paul
gossard qui est un élu républicain de
l'arizona et selon le témoignage de ces
deux sources anonymes à ce sénateur
républicain aurait promis une grasse
général pour une autre affaire en cours
afin de pousser ses deux organisateurs à
planifier ces manifestations écouter cet
extrait
notre impression était que c'était une
affaire conclue qu'il en avait parlé au
président dont le bureau ovale lors
d'une réunion sur les grâces et que nos
noms ont été mentionnés il travaillait à
soumettre les documents et à faire
signer les membres du groupe
parlementaire house freedom comme en
témoignage de leur soutien
alors ces deux sources expliquent avoir
eu en réalité des dizaines d'entretiens
avec des responsables politiques proches
de donald trump et si ces deux sources à
décide de parler aujourd'hui c'est parce
que distel elles ont été déçus par la
tournure violente des événements le 6
janvier et malgré leurs soutiens
politiques elles se disent aussi déçu du
comportement de donald trump on peut
aussi et peut-être surtout y voir une
façon pour ces deux sources anonymes de
redorer leur image puisque on comprend
dans leur quête publiées par rolling
stone qu'elle sont donc inquiété par une
autre procédure
hier en tout cas le fait qu'elle se
cache derrière cet anonymat n'est pas
vraiment du goût des personnes qui sont
incriminés dans leurs témoignages écouté
par exemple la réaction de la
parlementaire margerie teller green
ils parlent de leurs ressources et de
leurs sources et cite des sources mais
ne donne pas de nom ce qui me rappelle
tout le mensonge autour de la collusion
russe
ils parlent de leurs ressources et de
leurs sources et cite des sources mais
de nom mais ne donne pas de nom ce qui
me rappelle tout le mensonge autour de
la collusion russie
en tout cas ces deux personnes se disent
prêtes à témoigner désormais
publiquement devant la commission d'
enquête parlementaire en charge des
événements du 6 janvier on sait que les
élus qui forment cette commission
parlementaire ont déjà assigné des
anciens proche de donald trump en tant
que témoin que ce qui a mené à cette
bataille juridique puisque donald trump
veut lui tenté de garder la
confidentialité de ces échanges et de
ses communications lorsqu'il était à la
maison blanche le 6 janvier d'ailleurs
des médias américains révèlent ce mardi
qu'au moins cinq personnes issues
notamment du staff de la maison blanche
aurait commencé à avoir des discussions
avec cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire afin de collaborer sur les
travaux qui sont menés on sait cette
commission est jugée partisane par
donald trump et par ses soutiens mais
les membres de cette commission veulent
tenter de trouver là des éléments pour
attester d'une quelconque implication de
l'ancien président dans les violences
qui se sont déroulés le 6 janvier
dernier jose que le principal intéressé
a toujours démenti merci thomas bonnin
en direct de washington et pour en
parler nous sommes en direct depuis
houston aux états unis avec dave perkins
analyse politique partisan de donald
trump c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir dave perkins merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france dans le
cadre de l' attaque du capitole avec ces
accusations maintenant de complicité
alors tout est anonyme
mais ce que ces accusations ne vous
semblent tout de même crédible
moment je ne le pense pas j'ai étudié
les vidéos je suis les nouvelles
concernant ce que je peux faire une main
c'est sûr qu'ils essayent de découvrir
et ils connaissent grâce à mon sens la
réponse à toutes les questions qu'ils
posent et c'est vraiment un spectacle
pour la télévision afin de retourner le
public contre est donald trump ailerons
il s'agit vraiment d'un spectacle tout
misé professionnels afin d'influencer
l'équilibré gauche droite notamment
parce que tu raiden ne fait pas du tout
un très long travail et son taux de
popularité est en chute libre
je ne pense pas que ce qu'ils font on
aura un impact si ce n'est de retourner
le public contre donald trump et le
parti républicain si on vous suit bien
dave perkins l'intérêt du magazine
rolling stone c'est de déstabiliser
donald trump en tout cas de l'enfoncer
entre guillemets si vous me pardonnez
cette expression ça voudrait dire que ce
n'est pas un magazine fiables selon vous
est pas et pas sérieux
magazine rolling stone saurait être
sérieux mais
est un média qui est une part sérieux
puis après se veut un média de loisirs
puis redevient sérieux et donc il n'a
pas toujours le même vos deux qualités
il a a produit 2 à reims et des
entretiens très intéressant briard des
journalistes très talentueux
mais en l'occurrence ils sont attendues
dans le camp démocrate et il souhaite la
même chose que démocrate c'est à dire
qu'il souhaite lui hier à donald trump
est remis au parti républicain en vue
des élections de mi mandat les en vue
bien sûr des élections présidentielles à
venir car tout le monde a déjà décidé
que donald 30 jours et un rôle majeur à
nouveau un donc je ne fais pas confiance
aux rolling stones s'agissant de mener
des enquêtes politiques car sans aucun
doute ils ont un programme et on sait
évidemment la dimenc l'anc est donc se
poursuit ce serait justement une des
sources liées à cette enquête
saleh serait donc à penser si c'était
vrai c'est faux selon vous en tout cas
que ce putsch entre guillemets 1 devant
le capitole il aurait été non pas
spontanée mais orchestrée en haut lieu
dé proche de donald khamsa aurait des
conséquences quand même assez grave sur
cette enquête et sur donald trump n'est
ce pas
un jouisseur et
la fin déjà vu lors des trois années
d'enquêté concernant la collusion avec
la cie tous les jours les gens se
présenter devant les caméras en dix ans
nous avons les profs nous allons chasser
de la trempe du pouvoir et trois ans
plus tard il n'avait pas de preuves et
de l'attraper à la maison blanche
autant avoir des informations qui sont
en train de rassembler qui auront un
effet dévastateur contre donald trump
mais il le disait déjà lors de la
capture à paul avec et rien sur la
russie et lorsque les essais auxquels
ont restitué
au regard de l'histoire récents que ceux
que je connais bien j'ai vraiment dû la
crau qui vont vraiment réussir à porter
un coup majeur a donné un trempé aux
républicains au contraire si la cour
même se retourner contre les démocrates
et renforcer encore donald trump et le
parti républicain la commission spéciale
s'est prononcé la semaine dernière en
faveur de poursuites judiciaires en tout
cas pour entrave au travail du congrès
contre l'ancien conseiller donald trump
steve banane ça veut dire que l'ancien
président ait ciblé mais aussi son
entourage
douze de plus près cela fait partie de
leur stratégie ils attaquent d'autres
personnes qui ont encore beaucoup à
perdre donald trump est encore très
riche d'un type banane ce n'est pas non
plus le cadre d'autres personnes de son
cercle donc il attaque réussie de ces
personnes un quart et c'est d'obtenir
quelque chose de
handball en
outre profité du soutien de donateurs
sur les liens contre la russie estime
bananes non africains qui auraient pu
faire du mal à donald trump et là encore
aujourd'hui rien à dire qui pourrait
élire à donald trump a mano toujours
dans le tome 2 dont 1 30 ce type annoncé
au moins autant que moi que les
démocrates même des enquêtes vraiment
bâclé lui et qu'il ne s'agit que d'un
spectacle télévisé fini temps à changer
le point de la population américaine
est un steward a le droit de ne pas se
présenter devant les tribunaux de ne pas
prêter serment
se retrouver face
a narbonne un simulacre de justice qui
essaye de le pousser au parjure en
disant que s'il ne rappelle pas
exactement ce qu'il a dit auparavant
alors il s'agit d'un mensonge il
risquerait donc la prison pour parjure
si danone est trop intelligent pour
s'engager dans ce genre de piège et il
est donc de ne pas répondre à cette
convocation et je pense pas qu'ils
réussiront à le forcer à
témoigner dernière question défaire
keynes quatre anciens collaborateurs de
l'ancien président aurait reçu un
courrier de l'avocat du de donald trump
en leur demandant de ne pas répondre aux
convocations de la commission denquête
pourquoi les empêcher de parler
finalement s'il ne se reproche rien ce
qu'ils n'ont pas intérêt à les défendre
leur cause justement de vent devant les
enquêteurs
il est bien connu que la chose suivante
faire prêter serment à nogent et ensuite
leur poser de questions qui n'ont rien à
voir avec l'anglais mais qui sont liés à
d'autres choses qu'il souhaite savoir
cela or ces personnes à dire la vérité
concernant des discussions privant sur
des questions de financement
ce sont des justes ne riment pas
forcément illégale oui pour que l'on ne
veut pas forcément un rendre public il y
a un droit à la vie privée
à gré par exemple pour
3,4 et des conversations par exemple
aurait qu'un certain monsieur cohen qui
a renoncé à sotuba mais connaître
parfaitement le droit de demander à ces
gens
il témoigné car
ces personnes qui ont témoigné pour
peut-être qu'on ne saura jamais d'eux
qu'il s'agit de carreaux peut-être que
n'existent pas du tout en tout cas ce
que donald trump 10 et ne tombez pas
dans le piège qu'il tente pour vous
merci beaucoup de perkins nous avons
apporté votre opinion en direct sur rt
france ce soir
dans le reste de l'actualité le comique
19 qui continue de diviser à travers le
monde la défiance face à la vaccination
reste présente un peu partout sur le
globe tour d'horizon avec adrien
fonteneau
les jours se suivent et se ressemblent
quel que soit le pays alors que le coe
vie de dix neuf continue de tuer à
travers le monde et malgré une
vaccination qui progressent le
scepticisme persiste lui aussi à new
york ce lundi ils étaient encore des
milliers à défiler pour protester contre
les mesures du maire bill de blasio
après les enseignants et les soignants
en septembre la ville a étendu
l'obligation vaccinale à ses 160 mille
employés municipaux
vous ne pouvez pas choisir ce qui a du
sens pour vous et dire que ça a du sens
pour quelqu'un d'autre je me fous de
savoir qui se bat contre le communisme
j'en ai rien à faire de qui se bat
contre le socialisme ce pourquoi je me
base aujourd'hui c'est de ne pas être
piquée par une aiguille dont
l'efficacité n'a pas encore été prouvée
à notre époque celle du mon corps mon
choix vous devriez être en mesure de
choisir le type de vaccin que vous
souhaitez utiliser en particulier avec
ce vaccin qui suscite tant de réactions
négatives
je pense que cela mérite d'être défendue
et que les gens doivent se mobiliser
s'ils ne le font pas ils le regretteront
un jour
la barre des 700 mille morts franchi au
début du mois les etats unis demeurent
les plus touchés par la pandémie
quand l'australie fait partie des pays
épargnés grâce à des mesures très
restrictives pourtant avec moins de 1500
décès dans le pays est quasiment 260
jours de confinement à melbourne le
refrain reste le même
si à mais le gong vous avez un vrai
problème de santé bien vous ne pouvez
pas être soignée si vous n'êtes pas
vacciné c'est vraiment une blague
l'europe à elle fait le choix du pass
sanitaire qui s'est imposé dans
plusieurs pays à leipzig jr les
allemands ont occupé les rues jusque
tard dans la soirée pour protester
contre cette mesure alors qu'en italie
200 personnes entame un blocage de 48
heures du port de gênes une chose est
sûre le cobp et 19 n'en a pas fini de
diviser
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons du paysage énergétique
français alors que là comme 26 ouvre ses
portes ce week-end la france
pourra-t-elle atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 peut-on se passer du
nucléaire on tentera de répondre à cette
question rester avec nous
[Musique]
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
il on s'est vraiment un choix pour les
inspecteurs du guide michelin de mettre
cette année en particulier voilà moscou
en avant et sur ces dernières années nos
inspecteurs ont pu noter une vraie
évolution de la scène culinaire de
moscou et puis de plus en plus de
concept de restaurant et avec des chefs
qui ont une vraie signature dans leur
cuisine c'est en observant ce
développement que vous êtes dit on va
aller voir de plus près ce qui se passe
en russie moscou est un vrai carrefour
un vrai carrefour d'influencés un vrai
carrefour de deux cultures donc il ya un
vrai brassage donc il ya une très très
grande diversité des types de cuisine
moscou en particulier a une saveur
particulière
a ajouté à la scène gastronomique
mondiale
[Musique]
et si la prochaine crise financière
venait de chine evergrande c'est le nom
du géant chinois de la construction un
géant qui pourtant croule sous une
gigantesque dette tout va dépendre de la
façon dont l'état chinois va gérer la
chose est ce que il sauve les détenteurs
d'obligations en interne et qui plante
les détenteurs d'obligations
externe ou est ce que il règle la note
pour pour evergrande il suffit
quelquefois d'un maillon en pull my on
est gros plus c'est risqué d'un maillon
qui sautent dans cette chaîne pour avoir
des effets de propagation globaux
d'effet boule de neige nous sommes dans
un régime de prix administrés par les
banques centrales donc si vous voulez
200 milliards c'est rien pour une banque
centrale donc si elle veut régler le
problème evergrande demain et puis les
autres d'ailleurs un suffit qu'elle
fasse tourner la planche à billets et
aujourd'hui on est en train de tout
régler comme ça
[Musique]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on disait
dans les grandes entreprises
multinationales de saint gobain russie
ukraine on a beaucoup dit que bon
l'ouest et caïcos l'eau mais que l'est
et paul bert moi je suis convaincu à
titre personnel que il faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc les tubes serveuse il faut
réduire les émissions de carbone dans
les pays en développement sur partout
partout vous avez construit des usines
décarbonés vos des usines où on est mais
rien du tout comme carbone dans l'usiné
que ce soit nos émissions directes ou
alors des émissions liées à la
production d'électricité nous en avons
aujourd'hui dans le monde donc la
conscience écologique aussi l'existence
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les ong sont devenus 50 ans des acteurs
incontournables de la société moderne
par leur impact auprès des gouvernements
et du public confondant régulièrement
les grands principes avec leurs
objectifs politiques
ce sont des organisations non
gouvernementales mais pas des
organisations non politiques les ong
développent des stratégies d' influence
qui privilégie l'émotionnel sur le ratio
le sectarisme de la majorité d'entre
elles les amènent à des interprétations
qui exclut toute pensée ou comportements
n'allant pas dans leur sens et leur
condition n'hésitant pas à tordre les
faits et à utiliser tous les moyens pour
imposer leur vérité
[Musique]
il est 21h merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire à quoi pourrait ressembler
énergétique en france dans 30 ans alors
que la coop 26 ouvre ses portes ce
week-end le gouvernement se penche sur
plusieurs scénarios cosigne rapport aux
le réseau électrique français à l'appui
pour dit-on atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 alors peut-on se passer
du nucléaire on vous pose la question
vous pouvez toujours réagir sur le côté
g d'ayrté france
[Musique]
à cinq jours de la coop 26 inquiétudes
des divisions sont les maîtres mots
autour de la marche à suivre pour sauver
le climat le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson parle d'une
peur d'un possible échec de ce sommet
mondial à l'onu on se montre carrément
pessimiste parlant d'un aller simple
vers le désastre de son côté l'australie
vise la neutralité carbone en 2050 même
objectif pour la france qui réfléchis à
six scénarios proposés par le
gestionnaire national lui réseau du
transport d'électricité le résultat de
deux ans de travaux objectif orienter la
stratégie française en matière d'énergie
pour lutter donc contre le changement
climatique
on retrouve notre reporter nadège
abderrazak devant le ministère de la
transition écologique bonsoir neige
alors concrètement que proposent ces six
scénarios à l'étude
alors cette feuille de route stéphanie
shell prenait la construction de
nouveaux réacteurs nucléaires tout en
insistant sur la nécessité d'investir et
de développer les énergies renouvelables
alors dans ce rapport on parle notamment
du développement des énergies matures
c'est-à-dire des grands parcs éoliens et
solaires à terre et en mer l'objectif un
ca d'atteindre la neutralité carbone à
l'horizon 2050
mais nadège
présentation des scénarios rte se révèle
être partielle et donc partial nous
écologistes dénonçons cette manipulation
du gouvernement toute décision politique
sur l'avenir du système électrique
français recquiert pourtant sérieux et
transparence
mais pour yannick jadot ce rapport
nadège du gestionnaire du réseau
électrique français est biaisé en faveur
d' de l'exécutif pourquoi une telle
critique
absolument le candidat europe ecologie
les verts s'est montrée est très
critique le candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 alors il
estime que ce rapport met en avant l'
avantage économique du nucléaire quand
en réalité en tout cas selon lui le
renouvelable serait plus intéressant
économiquement yannick jadot par le même
de manipulation au du gouvernement
[Musique]
nahd nadège
est manifestement nadège le gouvernement
ce ne se démonte pas
absolument alors pour barbara e
pompili ce rapport du gestionnaire
électrique présente six scénarios sur
l'avenir du réseau français d'ici 2050
il permet de sortir des dogmes d'un côté
comme de l'autre dit elle ils permettent
également de sortir de ceux qui disent
que le nucléaire est la solution à tous
est de ceux qui disent que le
renouvelable peut tout régler
la neige adhère à zac nucléaire éolien
solaire quel mix énergétique en france
dans 30 ans dans quelle proportion les
énergies renouvelables doivent-elles
être développées peut-on se passer du
nucléaire en 2050 on attend toujours vos
réactions sur le compte et dégradent rt
france le débat est ouvert avec notre
face à face tout de suite
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler yves
contassot membre d'europe écologie les
verts c'est que valérie de bord
porte-parole de xavier bertrand bonsoir
à tous les deux merci d'être avec nous
il faut compter 100 avant d'entrer dans
le vif du débat sur cette question du
nucléaire déjà ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec yannick jadot qui dit que ce
rapport de la rte et est biaisé en
faveur de l'exécutif
écoutez on peut faire trois remarques
sur le rapport de ft eu d'abord il y
avait trois hypothèses de départ
possibles quitté celle de rte hypothèse
avec de la sobriété c'est à dire comme
on supprimait tout le gâchis les
surconsommations inutile
une hypothèse haute et une très haute
hertz a choisi l'hypothèse haute elle
n'a pas choisi la sobriété deuxième
élément on recalculé ses coûts
rte n'applique absolument pas toutes les
données qui sont celles de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie pas des
gauchistes pas des écologistes est
manifestement être a surestimé dans son
rapport
tous les codes et renouvelable est
sous-estimé tous les coûts du nucléaire
et enfin dernier élément
comme d'ailleurs le gouvernement r tu
envisages la relance d'une terre sur des
technologies qui aujourd'hui n'existe
pas ils'agit de le p 2 deuxième
génération ou des mrc totti
ni l'une ni l'autre de ces technologies
met au point aujourd'hui et dans le
meilleur des cas on nous dit qu'elle
arriverait peut-être
et l'ensemble 2040 donc on voit qu'on
n'est pas du tout dans la trajectoire
qui est celle de l'accord de paris de la
baisse des émissions et d'autre part
simplement de la baisse du prix de
l'énergie
valérie de bord donc pour revenir voilà
à cette question que je posais à
l'instant à yves contassot un rapport
biaisé justement en faveur de deux de la
politique que soit adopté le l'exécutif
et je penserai parce qu'un rapport on
n'a pas le compliment qu'on souhaite pas
forcément dire qu'ils les bleesés c'est
un peu facile après je considère
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est important pour
les français c'est la sûreté la qualité
et le coût de l'énergie on y voit
particulièrement en ces temps difficiles
où l'augmentation notamment du gaz
découlent liés aux films sont
extrêmement importants le commune de
veut effectivement garantir aux français
une énergie accessible à un tarif qui ne
soit pas trop important et nous qu'est
ce que nous voulons c'est que chaque
fois qu'on essaie de reculer sur le mix
énergétique qui doit être nous
considérons avant tout composée de
nucléaire eh bien nous nous retrouvons
dans une situation complexe je vais pas
revenir ici sur la fermeture de
fessenheim mais néanmoins on affirmer
personnel que s'est il passé c'est chez
moi
les allemands ont ouvert des centrales à
charbon et aujourd'hui on a des
difficultés d'alimentation à cause de
cela mais si cognathèque il se trouve
que ce n'est pas nous qui le disons
c'est vos propres amis qui sont en
alsace donc on voit très bien
aujourd'hui que les décisions qui ont
été prises par ce gouvernement
parfaitement idéologique trouvent leur
finalité et ne peuvent plus perdurer il
est absolument nécessaire de façon
pragmatique et
absolument secure est bien d'avancer sur
cette logique plus la logique étant
d'avoir une énergie décarbonée je
rappelle la réalité et comme si le
nucléaire est décapitée donc on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec michela une
énergie qu'on peut produire avec
également des moyens de production que
nous pouvons avoir de 2050 parce qu'il
ya moyen pour sa recherche de travail là
dessus et je trouverais c'est étrange de
ne pas emmener sur ses énergiques
l'éolien aujourd'hui est extrêmement
décriait à une qualité de rendement qui
est extrêmement me criait un niveau de
production est également très décriée et
puis il ya d'autres modalités sur les
caméras on va poursuivre évidemment ce
débat qui est déjà bien lancée on va
regarder une première réaction celle de
de pascal qui vous écris donc sur le
compte et les gradins d'ayrté france
objectivement si on tente de s'en passer
du nucléaire donc non seulement on le
paiera très cher financièrement mais
aussi climatiquement réaction
pragmatique yves contassot de pascal qui
voient les prix d'énergie grimpé à une
vitesse folle comme tous les français
clairement on ne peut pas s'en passer on
n'a pas plutôt les moyens de s'en passer
d'ailleurs barbara compilé la nuit elle
aussi difficile de s'en passer pour un
tas de raisons et la première économique
yves contassot
aile c'est tout la verte regardez le
prix du kilowattheure nucléaire
alors au delà du fait qu'on n'arrive
même pas à le produire pour l'instant
avec les opère qu'il s'agisse de la
france de la finlande 2 1 de
l'angleterre même de la chine qui est
obligés de les arrêter de personne
n'arrive à produire un kilowattheure
sérieusement d'une part en sécurité et
d'autre part le prix avancé est d'à peu
près cinq fois à six fois celui produit
par les énergies renouvelables donc
autrement dit le nucléaire coûte de plus
en plus cher sur le nucléaire français
il ya un mensonge gigantesque c'est
qu'on a en incorpore pas dans le prix du
nucléaire le prix de traitement des
déchets d'une part le prix de
démantèlement des centrales d'autres à
juste prendre un exemple brennilis
fermé en 1985
aujourd'hui on est à 40 fois le prix
estimé
en 85 pour son démantèlement qui n'a
toujours pas commencé car on ne sait pas
le faire et donc on dit en 2040 vous
entendez là en 2040 peut-être qu'on aura
fait le démantèlement de brennilis et
les déchets je rappelle quand même que
pour certains déchets la durée de vie
approche les trois cent mille ans
autrement dit vous imaginez le nombre de
générations derrière nous qui aurons à
gérer ses déchets évidemment tout ça on
dit on le prend pas en compte
financièrement sinon le nucléaire ne
serait pas du tout rentable et donc la
bonne solution
c'est évidemment l'énergie la moins
chère possible c'est-à-dire d'abord la
sobriété elle pour éviter le gâchis est
ensuite les énergies renouvelables qui
elle une fois l'installation mise en
place coûte quasiment rien alors fallait
les deux bars vous vous souvenez xavier
bertrand pour qui clairement le
nucléaire et l'a dit et en une énergie
d'avenir donc se dire que vous n'êtes
pas du tout sur la même ligne que notre
ami yves contassot ce soir
alors je crois que c'est un euphémisme
parce que si je suis la même logique que
la sienne et bien accords pourront dans
le prix l'éolien le coût patrimonial de
nos paysages détruite par l'éolien
incorporeront également le coût la
destruction
de ces pics et de leurs lourds en béton
qui sont aujourd'hui dans l'étal faisons
exactement la même chose ensuite il faut
être je pense extrêmement cohérent les
pragmatiques comme vous l'avez dit ce
qui est important c'est d'avoir aussi la
sécurité de l'alimentation
on voit très bien que le gars à ce n'est
pas ces kurdes en ce moment mouvant et
complexe
aujourd'hui je pense que là si on pourra
certainement être d'accord avec monsieur
concassant mais nucléaire
nous produisons chez nous en france nous
alimentons également de nombreux pays
donc c'est aussi de ce point de vue une
source intéressante de revenus et puis
ça permet d'avoir une sécurité
d'alimentation
donc quand la main il ne s'agit pas de
dire il faut aucune énergie renouvelable
ça serait dogmatique et il ne s'agit pas
d'aller là dessus il faut aujourd'hui
travailler sur les énergies du futur on
a d'ailleurs en la matière la chance
d'avoir en france des chercheurs
parfaitement intéressant et qui peuvent
apporter des solutions mais dire
aujourd'hui comme a tenté de le faire ce
gouvernement au début du quinquennat eh
bien nous allons de façon irrémédiable
et nous réfléchi supprimer le nucléaire
arrive à une situation inextricable
comme celle ci où maintenant
effectivement encore une fois par
pragmatisme le gouvernement dit on ne
peut pas s'en passer c'est aujourd'hui
ce qui a pu suivre et de moins cher mon
alimentation pour les français et donc
on revient pas dessus encore une fois on
aurait mieux fait de la fermer
fessenheim
yves contassot à tous les déçus je vais
vous laisser un répondre mais dans la
lignée de ce que nous dit avait d'abord
il ya ce message dans gêne en force les
gens à acheter des véhicules électriques
alors qu'en forte période hivernale en
france il ya justement des coupures de
courant ce n'est pas avec des éoliennes
que ça va réellement compenser nous dit
donc angèle
votre réponse justement sur
nucléaire qui est quand même la manière
la plus pérenne d'offrir du courant
aujourd'hui en france
écoutez moi je note les contradictions
dans ce qu'elle vient de dire valérie
debout on nous dit on à fermer
fessenheim qu'on est obligé de rouvrir
les centrales à charbon en allemagne et
deux minutes après nous dit avec le
nucléaire c'est merveilleux on arrive à
alimenter plein de pays autour alors
soit on n'a pas assez de production en
france et dans ces cas là il faut pas
nous dire que on en vendra tout le monde
c'est pas très sérieux en fait on le
sait bien on a aujourd'hui une
incapacité de gouvernement et sa dot pas
que de monsieur macron à avoir une
vision un peu sérieuse des choses on a
pris un retard considérable
je vais vous donner juste à un chiffre
la plupart des centrales nucléaires
arriveront à 50 ans à la même période
bien avant que les nouvelles centrales
nucléaires
envisagées sont en capacité de
fonctionner elles arriveront tout à
l'échéance à peu près en même temps avec
un risque majeur qui est de plusieurs
ordres d'abord un risque que ya des
incidents qu'elles soient plus en état
personne n'est capable aujourd'hui de
dire quelle est la sécurité d'une cuve
qui est le coeur d'une du système
nucléaire et qu'on ne peut pas changer
personne n'est capable de dire si ces
cuves peuvent résister plus de 50 ans
l'asn elle même dit je ne veux pas me
prononcer nous n'avons aucun retour
d'expérience donc un risque majeur
deuxième risque c'est un risque
financier s'il faut les refaire
c'est des dizaines de milliards par
enfin pas pour chaque centrale mais au
total on chiffre à environ 150 milliards
le renouvellement totalement illusoire
de penser qu'on peut le financer et donc
il ya un risque aussi c'est qu'on ait
des coupures mais gigantesque
d'électricité et que pour le coup on
n'arrive plus à faire face aux besoins
donc on voit bien que tout ça n'est pas
très sérieux pas très réfléchie et les
meilleurs experts d'ailleurs en
conviennent quelle que soit leur point
de vue sur le nucléaire et disque il ya
un risque qui est majeure
vous faire écouter yves contassot a pour
vous soutenir dans votre propos adrien
quoi tendance à la france insoumise
parti de jean luc mélenchon qui va
justement dans votre sens écoutée
atteindre la neutralité carbone en 2050
sans recourir au nucléaire c'est
possible affirmé le contraire n'est pas
sérieux c'est un choix politique étayée
par des experts c'est celui que nous
faisons avec jean luc mélenchon
d'abord un choix politique nous dit-on
chez mélenchon qui rajoute comme le
disais à l'instant yves contassot
comprend aussi un pari extrêmement
risqué avec le nucléaire c'est tout
simplement dangereux jean luc mélenchon
explique il ya des industries chimiques
qui sont concentrés dans les mêmes zones
que le nucléaire un accident et c'est
fini nous lisent et il à l'époque qu'est
ce que vous répondez à cette inquiétude
qu ont certains français
japon déjà la première chose c'est que
quand je parlais de la possibilité de
match park cela évidemment de la
technologie supputations et fin
connaisseur du sujet pour ne pas l'avoir
compris deuxième élément par rapport à
cela vous savez c'est pas parce qu'on a
peur de quelque chose qui va arriver en
2050 qu'on ne doit pas agir en 2021
aujourd'hui on a tout à fait la
possibilité est bien de mettre en place
des protections de mettre en place des
travaux notamment sur le retraitement
des déchets rappelle qu'elle le sujet et
notamment le projet 6 géo qui se trouve
également dans la région en meuse qui a
pour vocation de travailler sur le
retraitement des déchets avec un
enfouissement là que ce dispositif
travail existe depuis 20 ans on
travaille depuis vingt ans il ya des
tests qui se fait en la matière et il ya
des solutions qui commencent à émerger
et ce n'est pas en disant bien il va se
passer quelque chose en 2050 de vous ou
de vue strictement tout arrêté que ça va
permettre aux français d'avoir une
énergie de meilleure qualité sans
coupure et surtout un tarif raisonnable
c'est exactement l'inversé la peur
n'évite pas le danger et cette façon de
dire ne faisons rien et ajedou tout
n'est absolument pas sujette à mon allié
et co sud à venir donc nous ce que nous
pensons au contraire c'est qu'avec la
qualité de nos scientifiques avec la
qualité notre recherche avec notre
capacité toujours d'avoir une longueur
d'annonce et bien nous devons faire
confiance nous devons avancer nous
devons continuer les fectivement la
recherche ex constant la matière les
choses doivent progresser à gré y
compris et bien évidemment sur la
sécurité il ne s'agit pas de se départir
de sécurité et en france je pense que de
ce point de vue nous avons avec le
lancement des dispositifs suffisamment
contrairement à d'autres pays et
l'argent conviens avec vous monsieur
castro n'est pas le même système que
dans d'autres pays où nous soutiendrait
certainement car même discours en tout
cas dans notre vie ce n'est pas la même
chose donc regardons avant tout comment
nous nous assurons cette alimentation un
coût qui permette à chaque français
d'avoir aussi des traitements parce que
tout le monde doit pouvoir y accéder
encore une fois on est tous sous le
véhicule électrique c'est un petit peu
ce que disait la téléspectatrice total à
la première vous je l'imaginais y
compris le vélo électrique mais tout ça
il faut bien que ça s'anime enfin nos
matches et avec quoi hamou l'alimenter
si nous n'avons pas au moins cette
garantie avec un mix énergétique qui a
un pied concret et réel ce qui n'est
absolument pas le cas aujourd'hui les
autres étaient rachète noblat yves
contassot la réponse est le mot de la
fin pour vous la réponse elle est simple
d'abord dans les six scénarios de rtl il
y en a un qui est 100% renouvelable vous
l'oubliez un peu ça veut dire que même
rte reconnaît que 100% renouvelable
c'est techniquement faisable et que ça
permet de faire face à la consommation y
compris hôte qu'il retient qui est
pratiquement le double d'une
consommation qui sera basée sur la
sobriété et je vous renvoie d'ailleurs
au scénario mais
non
je ne peux pas vous laisser mentir je
suis d énergies renouvelables ça n'est
pas discutable vous pourrez prendre tous
les chiffres pairs en termes de
l'électricité ce sont les énergies
renouvelables ça n'est pas discutable
vous pouvez prendre tous les chiffres la
cour des comptes
cour des comptes le reconnaît elle parle
d'échec d'échec pour le p r les princes
les suivants sont estimées à mener main
sur le nucléaire
c'est pas le faire c'est parce que j'ai
dit ah bon j'ai dit le père n'est pas
tout le nucléaire vous pouvez pas dire
ça je veux dire c'est aujourd'hui qu'il
est aujourd'hui c'est que vous et vos
amis mais c'est tous les projets
aujourd'hui repose sur le p r ou des sms
qu'ils ne sont pas plus opérationnel
donc autrement dit vous faites un espèce
de paris
bah écoutez il y en a aucun qui
fonctionne c'est ce qu'elle jouait et
edf dix 10 ans aux études préalables
pour vérifier si un jour c'est faisable
et qu'en tout état cause ce ne sera pas
avant 2035 2040
mais nous les tout arrêter mais qu'ils
soient y être arrivé c'est pas en 2050
qu'on va commencer vous avez l'air de
dire que des règlements stricts
et ben oui si
je note simplement que l'allemagne à
30000 éoliennes nous avons zéro
éoliennes offshore 00 nous sommes très
très belle l'allemagne se chauffe au
chardon se conformer
vous avez changé
merci en tout cas merci à tous les oeufs
suisses habilitées
merci
merci également à fédérer de bord
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce face à
face ce soir et la crise de l'énergie et
la flambée des prix qui touche toute
l'europe on s'intéresse au soir à
l'espagne le gouvernement vient
d'adopter plusieurs mesures d aides
débloquées pour les familles confrontées
à des factures de l'électricité qui
atteignent des records dans le pays est
détaillé avec notre correspondante à
barcelone clémentine laurent le prix de
l'électricité continue de flamber ici en
espagne a atteint désormais des records
le coût du mégawattheure était ce marty
2 225 euros et 36 centimes bien sûr
c'est une situation qui met en
difficulté notamment les particuliers
mais aussi les industriels en espagne
ici cinq grandes entreprises ont dû
limiter leur production car l'énergie
leur coûtait trop cher alors face à ce
problème l'état espagnol a décidé de
prendre des mesures et notamment ce
mardi d'élargir un peu plus les aides
désormais les consommateurs les plus
précaires recevront une aide qui pourra
couvrir jusqu'à 70% de leur facture
d'électricité
il devrait également recevoir en
décembre un chèque d'une valeur de 90
euros pour les aider à se chauffer cet
hiver pour le gouvernement cède
additionnelle représente un total de 100
millions d'euros en investissements
énormes alors c'est 1,2 million de
foyers ici en espagne qui devraient
bénéficier de ces aides et notamment ici
à barcelone je vous propose d'écouter
les réactions des habitants
là ça use il n'y a pas de justification
pour des prix pareils ils les aident
finalement nous les payons tous de notre
poche ce que nous devrions avoir c'est
un prix juste et il faut arrêter de
financer des lobbys complètement égoïste
et à vide qui sont ceux qui en profitent
le plus
l'augmentation est hors de contrôle et
même avec les aides si on a une famille
avec des salaires normaux et surtout si
on a des enfants on ne peut pas payer
l'électricité tout en poursuivant notre
rythme de vie habituel donc je pense que
c'est démesuré et les aides devraient
être plus importantes
le prix de l'électricité est trop élevé
et à cause de la pandémie l'économie
s'est effondrée et les gens n'ont pas de
ressources pendant que tous les jours
l'électricité augmentent alors jusqu'où
on va arriver les aides que le
gouvernement dit qu'il va donner il faut
attendre parce qu'on nous promet
toujours des choses et quand ça arrive
c'est toujours au minimum pour le quai
6ème place et simple au matin et c'est
d'ailleurs au minimum ces aides sont
également destinés aux entreprises le
gouvernement espagnol espère les aider à
faire face à l'augmentation du prix de
l'électricité et ainsi protéger leur
contrat mais l'enjeu planétaire du
réchauffement climatique au sommaire
d'un autre rendez vous international le
sommet de l'initiative verte du
moyen-orient à ryad l'occasion pour le
monde arabe de s'accorder sur une
feuille de route écologique commune
présente au rang au sommet la tunisie
poursuit sa recherche de capitaux pour
sortir de sa crise financière ont fait
le point avec notre correspondante à
tunis abbas m shelly un sommet
international qui résonne comme un test
pour la nouvelle chef du gouvernement
tunisien najlae bouden à ryad pour dix
jours dans le cadre du sommet de
l'initiative verte du moyen-orient d'un
locataire du palais de la kasbah appelé
les participants à faciliter l'accès au
financement pour une transition
écologique durable une transition
écologique qui devra passer par la
promotion de la recherche scientifique
et l'innovation et la diversification
des sources de production d'énergie
écoutez nous pouvons transformer les
défis auxquels nous faisons face en
occasions de collaboration et
d'entr'aide entre nos pays dans la prise
de décision la mise en place d'une
stratégie environnementale et
l'encouragement du financement des
programmes de développement durable en
marge de ce sommet la première femme
chef du gouvernement du monde arabe en a
profité pour multiplier les rencontres
avec ses homologues arabes et les
représentants de certaines puissances
mondiales dont le prince héritier
mohammed ben salman l'occasion pour
l'envoyé spécial de kayes zayed en
arabie saoudite d'accélérer les
négociations avec grillades qui a promis
au pays un soutien financier vital à sa
sortie de crise économique présent à ses
côtés pour ce rendez vous international
othman jerandi le ministre tunisien des
affaires étrangères a réaffirmé à
l'issue de la rencontre de la délégation
tunisienne avec le prince héritier le
soutien de ryad aux mesures
exceptionnelles prises par le président
sayen le 25 juillet dernier le diplomate
tunisien a assuré que l'arabie saoudite
se tiendra aux côtés de la tunisie dans
tous les domaines annonçant de fait la
mise en place prochaine d'une commission
mixte entre les deux parties pour
discuter des dossiers de coopération et
d'investissement autre soutien celui des
etats unis eux aussi présents en arabie
saoudite
à l'issue d'une rencontre avec najlae
bouden john kerry et l'envoyé spécial
américain pour le climat a laissé
entendre que washington continuait de
suivre de très près le dossier tunisien
selon l'ancien secrétaire d'état des
états unis des concertations seraient en
cours entre des parties tunisiennes
était partie américaine concernant les
modalités d'appui qui seront accordés à
la tunisie sans donner plus de
précisions écouter les états unis ont
confiance dans le gouvernement tunisien
actuel et serons aux côtés de la tunisie
durant la prochaine période un sommet
écologique aux allures d'opération de
levée de fonds pour la tunisie car si le
réchauffement climatique est une
préoccupation pour elle comme pour ses
partenaires le spectre du défaut de
paiement semblent menacer le pays du
jasmin a bien plus court terme et c'est
la fin de cette émission merci d'avoir
suivi rendez vous demain dès 20 heures
pour un nouveau numéro 10 là n'oubliez
pas de réagir sur rt france sur notre
compte télégramme
[Musique]
chacun prétend détenir la vérité trop
souvent il ne s'agit que de spéculations
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que